vous l'hégémonique comme les messieurs
bien son nom
on peut voir si ça va
18h julia vient de terminer ses cours en
visio l'étudiante en master à la
sorbonne partageant thé avec monique
l'été c'est
comment dire c'est un rituel un temps
qu'elle prenne pour parler de leur
journée elles ne sont pas grands mères
et petites filles mes colocataires
depuis trois ans arrivé en france en
2018 julia ne veut pas se retrouver seul
sans nécessairement partager une
colocation avec des jeunes de son âge
elle se tourner vers l'association
ensemble2générations qui fait le nez
entre seniors et jeunes on peut partager
d'autres activités comme par exemple
aller au cinéma au théâtre
surtout avant de covin n'a pas
énormément on peut on regarde la télé
ensemble parfois je fais la cuisine ou
alors j'ai accompagné mon nico marché le
dimanche
on bavarde voilà on fait parfois
on regarde des émissions où
je les fais lire ce que j'ai des devoirs
que j'ai fait des dossiers que j'ai
écrit pour un master au décès de son
époux money boké ne veut pas être seule
chez elle mais ne souhaite pas quitter
son domicile ses enfants découvrent
l'association en moyenne les colocations
dure deux ans c'est un accompagnement je
peux pas dire les choses se font même
les choses imprévues ben on les prend
puis on sent marange mais on n'est pas
maniaque ni sur l'heure du déjeuner ni
digne et si je voulais envie de
téléphoner montant ses parents pareil
moi je dis aussi ben moi je peux pas
inventer leurs noms mais les choses
elles se sont naturellement et c'est ça
que je trouve vraiment formidable giulia
devrait rester chez monique le temps de
terminer son master l'étudiante est la
sixième personne accueillie par monnet
qui gardent contact avec ses
colocataires même après leur départ de
la maison comme un lien familial